nazaneen-e man detox drama and where she
won't be filming her new show the
Platinum life it's classy
ET recently sat down with the 31 year
old model where she opened up about her
new reality series which follows an
elite group of music's most savvy women
and their chart-topping significant
others being aged 2 Miguel is fun as
what's the feedback been like for you so
positive I'm so grateful that people
love the show in four words for people
that haven't seen the show okay describe
what it's about in four words
give me four good Colts okay it's classy
okay it can be you know a little catty
okay and you're with a group of girls
for a long period of time yeah you know
stuffs bound to happen
you know things mend and it's okay it's
okay that's what makes this kind of show
interest yeah you see real relation real
relationship so classy caddy fun and one
more one more one more
let me see yeah yeah we can say dramatic
why not people love drama I'm telling
you and we spoke to Ostia and Alicia
Emily and they said that you were the
one that got them involved in the show
and you were like I've got to do this
yes so I've known both of them for a few
years yeah and you know the creator and
producer approached me about the show
just like do you know any other girls
that would be great for this yeah and
those two popped into my mind I was like
ah SIA and Alicia they're beautiful
there's they're smart they have their
own things going to them and it's just
like they were the perfect fit and I
needed friends you know on the show yes
I going into this I didn't know the
other girls so there is a lot of
jet-setting and drama on the show we saw
a little bit of unfold that fight
between the two is that gonna you know
what it hum do ahead it does play out
yeah and you'll see it throughout the
season you will definitely see how ASEAN
crystal mend things yeah and where it
ends up which is very
interesting actually I think I think
you'll have to wait till the very last
episode to see that
do you take sides are you more of the
peacemaker I'm definitely the peacemaker
but in the end my loyalty is always to
hacia yeah always because I've known her
yeah that's my girl I've known her for a
long time I have her back we talk each
other off the ledge we say like when I'm
about to lose it she's like okay Naz
he's gotta calm down yes and then I'm
the same with her yeah it's just like
okay let's look at it this way let's
change our perspective is it worth it
no all right let's fall back so we have
fan questions coming into on this iPad
that's why this is sitting here I forgot
to explain okay so Dee wants to know is
anything off-limits
what do you refuse to share with the
audience you know what I don't film in
my home okay so you guys will not see
our house we won't see the blue couch
you won't see the Blue Dream No so
comfortable to bone on it's like I
wanted to keep my home as sacred as
possible
you